next question today hey David should
teachers be allowed to discuss politics
in the classroom why or why not so first
of all we've got to understand that
there's a kind of practical element to
the question of politics in the
classroom and then there's also a
question of taboo so when we talk about
whether your dentist should discuss
politics it's a different conversation
than whether teachers should discuss
politics and discuss is also different
from advocate for or Lobby right when
your dentist discusses politics it's
really just a risk to them because if
you don't agree with their politics or
you don't like the fact that they're
talking about politics you can just go
to another dentist assuming that there's
a sort of market of dentists that are
reasonably priced and accessible in your
area when teachers talk about politics
it's different because of the idea in
society that teachers are in a position
of authority when it comes to knowledge
and we presumably I think most parents
don't want teachers biasing our children
particularly if they're biasing our
children in ways that are not in line
with our personal politics because the
children may not be able to
differentiate from just like normal
classroom material and the teacher
advocating politics this is why
advertising to children is actually so
pernicious there's a period of time when
children don't understand the difference
between just fun programming and
something that's trying to get you to
buy a product and that's why advertising
the kids is pernicious and presumably
the same thing could happen when
teachers mix classroom material with
politics I do think that if we're going
to talk about this seriously it's got to
be divided between sort of like
elementary school middle school high
school starts to become a gray area and
college I truly couldn't tell you the
politics of almost any of my elementary
school teachers and I do think that's
sticking to the curriculum in a way
that's not overtly political does make
sense in American public schools in a
lot of classes we just don't need
politics in Nath class for example there
are areas though once you get into
science once you get into Human
Geography there are political realities
that are either implicit or unavoidable
in those there
and I still think in those cases
teachers should be able to keep the
advocacy to a minimum don't advocate
necessarily for particular candidates
for example but in science class you've
got to talk about the environment how do
you not talk about climate change
III don't believe climate change is
political it's just the reality but
there are people who do but teachers
have to be able to talk about that it's
just the world around us that they're
describing in college it gets different
I think but more call more more college
politics in the classroom is okay
advocating for or against specific
candidates maybe it should be kept out
of the classroom but we're talking about
adults we're talking about people who
are better able to identify what's a
personal view what is coursework there's
no question that the underlying
philosophy and subject matter in a lot
of college classes is inherently
political and pretending that it can
just be kept out is not reasonable and
you're actually starting to do damage to
students if you artificially keep
politics out so as with most things the
answer is it depends it depends what
we're talking about
it depends what age we're talking about
but some political realities in the
classroom are not only unavoidable they
should be a advisable they're actually
advisable so that people students have a
realistic understanding of what is going
on in the world